[Música]
os lo advertimos en un pasado vídeo aquí
en visual política el nuevo presidente
de corea del sur el conservador y un
socio está siendo todo un terremoto
político desde que se hizo con la
presidencia wright semana que iun no
anuncia un cambio importante en el país
claro que he visto el historial que
tienen los presidentes surcoreanos a la
hora de cumplir sus promesas ahora que
están muy pero que muy atentos de lo que
finalmente hace y lo que no hace
[Música]
en la historia de la democracia
surcoreana los presidentes cumplen de
media en torno al 30 por ciento de sus
compromisos electorales porque si en
corea del sur- se cuentan estas cosas el
ex presidente muy por ejemplo ha
cumplido apenas el 17 por ciento según
los datos provisionales claro que
hablamos de estadísticas que son en
política no siempre funcionan no todos
los compromisos tienen el mismo peso sea
como sea el hecho de que el presidente y
uno no provenga de la política
profesional coreana puede hacer que esta
estadística mejore con creces por ahora
si algo podemos decir es que el tipo
parece que tiene ganas
[Música]
de momento la comida que el nuevo
presidente parece querer dibujar se
diferencia bastante de la que dejó el
expresidente mundo ahora bien queréis
saber exactamente cuáles son los
primeros pasos que está tomando hyung
para relanzar corea del sur podrían ser
la puerta para un nuevo despegue
económico en qué consiste en la práctica
el giro a la derecha ha prometido por
este presidente pues bien en este vídeo
vamos a responder a estas y otras
preguntas pero antes habéis oído hablar
de nuestro boletín exclusivo para
patronos habéis oído hablar de la tan
político de los productos exclusivos que
no están a la venta en ningún otro sitio
pues amigos amigas si os gusta lo que
hacemos si queréis contribuir a que esta
comunidad siga creciendo y mejorando
podéis encontrar todo esto y más en
nuestro patrón en la comunidad de patria
dónde visual políticos dejamos enlace la
descripción y por supuesto un millón de
gracias a todos los que ya nos apoyáis
pero dicho esto arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos amigas el sistema
político de corea del sur es
presidencialista pero quizás una de sus
características más notables es que las
elecciones legislativas y las
presidenciales no coinciden en la misma
fecha es decir que el presidente del
país puede tener que gobernar sin
mayoría del parlamento que es justamente
el escenario con el que se encontró de
un sobrio concretamente entre el día 10
de mayo del 2022 que fue cuando asumió
la presidencia y abril del 2024 tendrá
que gobernar sin remedio con un
parlamento hostil
esto supone que al menos durante dos de
los cinco años que dura su mandato el
presidente puede estar atado de pies y
manos si no logra el apoyo de la
oposición en la asamblea nacional bueno
eso siempre y cuando no decida gobernar
a golpe de decreto presidencial que por
cierto es exactamente lo que parece que
va a ocurrir
[Música]
en corea del sur no se requiere que la
cámara legislativa apruebe todos y cada
uno de los decretos presidenciales lo
que le otorga al presidente amplios
poderes ya que básicamente le permite
introducir grandes cambios sin necesidad
de alcanzar grandes consensos y aunque a
largo plazo estas medidas puedan ser
fácilmente revocadas pueden llegar a
tener importantes consecuencias sobre la
vida política económica y social del
país
ah
el caso es que de momento las primeras
propuestas y los primeros cambios ya
están aquí juzga por vosotros mismos
al mercado y menos estado
[Música]
como ellos contamos en el pasado vídeos
sobre el giro de timón en corea del sur
es que si hay algo que caracteriza a iun
es que no le gusta ni un poquito nada
absolutamente nada que huela a políticas
de izquierdas ni en la sociedad ni
tampoco en lo económico bueno o al menos
eso es lo que dicen sea como sea es en
la parte económica donde previsiblemente
más cambios se van a producir durante
los próximos años y son tan relevantes
que queréis que os diga nos obliga a sí
o sí a contaros los en visual político
pero bien en primer lugar el nuevo
presidente ya ha anunciado las medidas
centrales de su plan económico a 5 años
son ya públicas así que no hablamos de
promesas ni de elucubraciones sino de
intenciones firmes y entre ellas reducir
las regulaciones a la actividad de las
empresas y las bajadas de impuestos son
las claras protagonistas se mejorarán
drásticamente las regulaciones y
esquemas que socavan la competitividad
empresarial y desalienta en el espíritu
emprendedor las circunstancias
económicas actuales dentro y fuera del
país son muy graves en tiempos de crisis
necesitamos hacer cambios para estar más
orientados al mercado y hacer que el
sector privado dirija toda la economía y
un socio de hecho tanto el ministro de
finanzas chuck jones como otros
ministros han dejado muy pero que muy
claro en un comunicado que el núcleo el
plan económico del gobierno de iun será
sobre todo la desregulación
[Música]
con el nuevo plan económico el gobierno
se compromete a minimizar la
intervención estatal en el mercado y
promover el cambio de modelo económico
hacia uno en el que el sector privado y
las empresas sean los protagonistas
dominantes asimismo el plan también
incluye reducir el tipo máximo del
impuesto de sociedades del 25 al 22 por
ciento el mismo nivel que había en 2018
revirtiendo por tanto los incrementos
liderados por münchen en esta línea y
esto es importante también se plantea
una revisión del sistema tributario para
introducir una exención de impuestos a
las ganancias repatriadas a korea el
objetivo es resolver de una vez por
todas el problema de la doble imposición
sobre las actividades de las empresas
coreanas en el extranjero
y ahí no termina todo
como no también quiere que en corea se
emprendan más y se creen más startups
así que para conseguirlo su idea es
otorgar mayores créditos fiscales por
ejemplo mediante la ampliación de las
exenciones a las 6 toca options que son
una forma de retribución a los
trabajadores que consisten en entregar
acciones de la propia empresa en lugar
de efectivo pues bien de los 50 millones
de wang actuales y luego gobierno quiere
cuadriplicar la exención de tributación
hasta los 200 millones unos ciento
cincuenta y cuatro mil dólares es decir
que si cobrasen acciones hasta esa
cantidad no tienes que tributar con ello
el gobierno espera poder atraer a más
trabajadores de alta cualificación a las
startups y que éstas puedan pagarles una
buena parte de su salario con acciones
en lugar de con efectivo gana la empresa
ganan los trabajadores y ganar gobiernos
eso permite incrementar el número de
emprendimientos y es que no olvidéis que
estamos hablando de crear el sur un país
donde la gente que sueña
fundamentalmente con trabajar en los
grandes conglomerados gracias
precisamente a sus altos sueldos lo que
les permite a estos grandes grupos
comportarse como una especie de
aspiradora del talento una aspiradora
que daña la competitividad de unas
pequeñas empresas generalmente poco
desarrolladas ya os hemos contado alguna
que otra vez quiere enorme problema de
dualidad que en este campo tiene corea
del sur- hablar de las grandes y de las
pequeñas empresas es casi como hablar de
dos países totalmente diferentes luego
otra de las medidas económicas
anunciadas es la modificación del
impuesto de sucesiones y ojo porque este
no es un tema menor
por ejemplo los que nos seguís desde
hace tiempo visual político puede que ya
hayáis visto este vídeo y los que no
bueno creo que estos titulares dicen
bastante una factura del impuesto sobre
sucesiones que no puedes comprender 10
mil 800 millones de dólares la familia
samsung en corea del sur también donará
miles de millones de dólares en obras de
arte incluidos picassos y monedas el
alto impuesto de sucesiones obstaculiza
el espíritu empresarial y es que amigos
amigas siguen con el sur tiene una de
las presiones fiscales más bajas de la
ocde morirse en cambio puede salir muy
pero que muy caro siempre y cuando eso
sí tengas dinero porque según el
servicio nacional de impuestos de corea
tan sólo el 2,9 por ciento de los
herederos de personas fallecidas
tuvieron que pagar este impuesto en 2020
pero es que hablamos de un impuesto que
en corea puede llegar a ser de hasta el
50 por ciento incluso entre padres e
hijos porque este impuesto sigue una
escala progresiva con algunas
deducciones al mejor estilo del impuesto
sobre la renta así que entendéis ahora
porque los herederos del ico y el
expresidente del grupo samsung que es el
mayor conglomerado empresarial del país
tienen que afrontar esa abultada factura
[Música]
pues bien aunque este impuesto afecte
fundamentalmente a la gente que tiene
bastante dinero ya cada uno si os parece
más o menos justo lo cierto es que su
impacto sobre la economía puede llegar a
ser considerable y es que veréis me
explico como los principales
conglomerados empresariales en coreas
son dirigidos por una misma familia que
por tanto son heredados cuando alguien
fallece la factura puede ser tan alta
que ésta puede terminar afectando a la
propia empresa por ejemplo los herederos
pueden terminar en udaondo se para pagar
el impuesto poniendo como garantía
recursos de las empresas lo que puede
limitar las nuevas inversiones o las
nuevas contrataciones de trabajadores y
luego sobre todo esto incentiva que
muchas personas saquen dinero del país y
emprendan negocios fuera pues bien os
guste más os guste menos y el caso es
que esto es lo que yo quiere cambiar
ahora aunque eso sí todavía ni siquiera
él parece saber exactamente cómo
demonios lo hará
y
al margen de la anterior el plan de iun
también incluye otras medidas fiscales
muy importantes como la abolición del
impuesto sobre las plusvalías de capital
para todos los inversores cuyas
ganancias no superen los 15 mil 500
dólares al año a cambio la idea es
aplicar un pequeño impuesto sobre
aquellos que tengan más de 77 millones
de dólares en acciones también se
permitirá posponer el pago del impuesto
de donaciones en el caso de recibir un
negocio de un familiar y se ampliarán
los incentivos fiscales para las
inversiones en tecnologías estratégicas
como los semiconductores
[Música]
pues bien así es como yo quiero hacer
mucho más competitiva a la economía
surcoreana e intentar sortear la crisis
que parece se avecina pero un momento
porque las medidas fiscales no son ni
mucho menos los únicos cambios que este
presidente quiere sacar adelante hay
mucho más es un plan estrella para
devolverle su viejo vídeo a korea
atentos
y el giro de 180 grados
[Música]
amigos amigas el cambio que yo tiene la
cabeza no consiste sólo en bajar cuatro
impuestos y a correr nada más lejos de
la realidad el nuevo presidente quiere
dar un giro de 180 grados en algunos de
los temas más controvertidos y delicados
como por ejemplo la política energética
o las pensiones y aquí yo parece
dispuesto a cumplir una de sus grandes
promesas una de las propuestas estrella
de su campaña electoral apostar
fuertemente por la energía nuclear de
hecho el gobierno anunciado yo anticipo
del plan con el que quieren conseguir la
neutralidad de carbono para el año 2050
lo que ocurre es que en lugar de hacerlo
con las renovables como fuente principal
en este caso tienen que la energía
protagonista así a la nuclear y que las
renovables después sean su apoyo yo pide
un mix energético racional con lo de
racional a lo que se refiere sobre todo
es a que el viejo plan de mont para la
descarbonización del país pues parecía
de todo menos algo realista el modelo
del anterior gobierno combinaba el
cierre progresivo de las plantas
nucleares con una apuesta salvaje por
las renovables el problema es que para
poder llevarlo a cabo el peso de las
renovables tenía que crecer hasta el 61
y el 71 por ciento del mix energético
algo que la mayoría de expertos pues
consideran simple y llanamente no
factible
por contra el nuevo gobierno ya ha
anunciado que volverá a retomar la
construcción de los dos reactores
nucleares cancelados por el anterior
gobierno de münchen y que también
alargará la vida útil de aquellos que
estén próximos a su límite y eso no es
todo además planea lanzar la
construcción de varios reactores
nucleares nuevos para aumentar el 27,4
al 34 por ciento el peso de la energía
nuclear en la producción eléctrica en el
medio plazo también buscará introducir
en los países los reactores modulares
pequeños o sml que se perfilan actores
destacados en el futuro de la energía
nuclear eso sí el gobierno seguirá
apoyando el despliegue de energías
renovables pero la idea en última
instancia es eliminar para 2050 la
producción de electricidad mediante gas
y carbón que suponen al día de hoy el
66% del mix energético surcoreano
luego sobre el tema de la vivienda del
plan económico que se ha presentado
contempla también reducir los impuestos
a los propietarios esto es así puedan
reducir el precio de los alquileres y
del 11 el peculiar sistema de
arrendamiento surcoreano
dado que los riesgos a corto plazo
permanecen en el mercado del alquiler el
gobierno busca dar respuestas
preventivas extendiendo los beneficios
fiscales y financieros y aumentando la
oferta yuki un ministro de finanzas y
sobre este último campo sobre la oferta
el gobierno se ha comprometido a
desvelar pronto un plan para construir 2
millones y medio de nuevas viviendas en
el país veremos pero de todas quizás la
reforma más delicada es precisamente la
de las pensiones
[Música]
era del sur es el país con el
envejecimiento demográfico más acelerado
de toda la ocde y se considera que su
actual modelo de pensiones basado en un
sistema de capitalización mediante un
fondo de pensiones público no será capaz
de hacer frente al número de
pensionistas que habrá en un futuro
próximo el propio presidente y uno ha
dicho claramente que en su opinión el
actual modelo supone una carga para las
generaciones futuras por eso entre otras
medidas quiere aumentar la edad mínima
de jubilación de los 60 a los 65 años o
incluso eliminar la edad de jubilación o
otorgar beneficios a las empresas para
que recontraten a jubilados
y ojo o porque esto no es ninguna broma
según la oficina de estadística
surcoreana la población en edad de
trabajar se reducirá en más de un 35%
durante las próximas tres décadas un
fenómeno que amenaza con hundir la
producción al tiempo que el gasto
público podría dispararse no sólo en
pensiones sino también en sanidad y
servicios sociales pero este tema es tan
importante que le dedicaremos
específicamente un próximo vídeo lo que
no quiere decir que hayamos terminado en
absoluto ya os he dicho que este nuevo
presidente ha llegado con ganas la
reforma de las instituciones públicas es
una tarea que no se puede demorar más
las evaluaciones de las instituciones
deben llevarse a cabo de manera estricta
los recursos económicos deben usarse
sólo donde sean necesarios y deben
gastarse favorablemente y con
generosidad para los verdaderamente
débiles de la sociedad que necesiten
desesperadamente el apoyo del gobierno y
un socio y veremos en qué termina todo
de momento lo que también ha cambiado
radicalmente ha sido la política
exterior ahora mucho más próxima a eeuu
ya japón y más beligerante hacia china y
corea del norte lo que ha supuesto el
abandono de la equidistancia del
anterior gobierno del mundo y los
grandes asuntos internacionales fijados
hayden y hyung valoran más ejercicios
militares en medio de tensiones con
corea del norte
alineamiento de corea del sur con eeuu
en detrimento de china a medida que el
nuevo gobierno surcoreano profundiza los
lazos económicos y de seguridad con eeuu
los expertos advierten que es probable
que la larga relación de seguro con
china sufra tan pronto como sea posible
tenemos que regresar a los mejores días
de corea y japón si no logramos eso por
mucho que hablemos del futuro de asia no
creo que sea realista hyun wook min
nuevo embajador surcoreano en japón pero
bien creo que con todo esto que os hemos
contado la pregunta es clara creéis que
si realmente se cumplen todas estas
medidas corea podría volver a vivir un
nuevo despegue económico creéis que son
suficientes para recuperar la
competitividad del país dentro y fuera
de sus fronteras porque dejándonos por
aquí abajo vuestras respuestas y ahora
si este vídeo se resultó interesante no
olvidéis darle al aek y suscribiros a
visor político para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras novedades una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]